[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you so much to my 15.280
students for nominating me
for this Teaching with
Digital Technology award.
We are obviously living
at a very important time
for higher education.
And we have collectively,
the opportunity
to reinvent how we're
delivering that type of content.
And I'm very much looking
forward to understanding
how collectively we find
new ways of delivering
technological content
to our students
to empower them to
use them in practice
but also to enhance their
educational experience.
The materials that we explore
and the sense of community
that we foster provides us
with the space and opportunity
to showcase our care
for one another.
And so once we had to face
the tragedy of COVID-19,
the means to express
our care and our joy
for being together
changed, but the foundation
remains the same.
My main approach to
teaching is really
oversharing in the interest
of building community.
I think that there can be no
real learning without trust.
And there can be no
trust without sharing
our own vulnerabilities.
And it just so happened that
the week of the campus closure,
we were discussing the
importance of connectedness
to place for human well-being.
So I immediately
asked the students
to think about what
it feels like when
the place that you
feel most connected to
is wrested from you.
Could this help us
empathize with the plight
of displaced peoples in
the world, for instance?
I wanted the students to
be anthropologists studying
this strange, new reality and
for that spirit of curiosity
to empower them and
to give them strength.
The different life
circumstances out
of which we make meaning, what
we often call our backgrounds,
a fitting metaphor
perhaps for the Zoom era,
has now come ever
to the foreground.
Remote teaching
was a heartbreak,
though it had its
unexpected boons as speaking
with students fixed in
equally-sized video boxes made
our discussions more democratic
though also made clear because
of the absence of
students unable reliably
to connect how far we have to
go in building this commons,
a fact highlighting the real
danger in which US and world
democracy now find
themselves, a peril that
must see us confront
racial injustice,
digital division, public
health catastrophe,
and the rise of unreason.
We threw away all
or most of our plans
in the interest of
getting the best learning
experience to our students.
When we first got word
that this semester was
going to be online,
one of the thoughts
that went through
my head was how
is a two-inch high,
two-dimensional version of me
possibly going to
compete with all
of the other things that are
on student's computer screens.
The first time I set
up a graph, I actually
walked off screen and then did
a little computer trickery.
And it looked like
I walked inside
of the graph inside of my slide.
Luckily, MIT has great
resources in digital learning,
such as the videotaping
rooms and the MITx system.
When the class was
moved online, I
decided to use OneNote
as my virtual blackboard.
It's quite easy to use.
Writing and drawing on
it feel really smooth.
Catsoop is free and
open source software.
It's freely available online.
And over the past
several semesters,
we've seen a pretty
steady increase
in the number of
subjects using it at MIT.
And sometimes,
these are subjects
that are very different
from the ones that I teach.
And so it's been extra
neat to see the things
that they're doing with
the software and the ways
that they're extending it.
As well as reproducing
all of the key features
of in-person lectures and office
hours as much as possible,
the other guiding
principle of flexibility
meant making the course
content as accessible
as possible in as many
formats as possible.
This is a very hands-on class.
We set the foundation by
going through the calculations
that an astronomer
will make in order
to determine what exposure
time they should use when
at the telescope.
The students were
able to do this
for the target of their
choice and then submit
this as a request to the
Elliot 24-inch telescope
at Wallace Observatory.
Although they weren't there
for the actual experiments,
by watching the videos
and then talking with me
and listening to my
presentations in the lab times
and then meeting
with us individually
about their spectra, they
were able to back this
up and talk about their
peptide to each other and us.
A one-on-one Zoom conference
is very productive
and has the advantage that the
student can record the session
so that if we talk
and say something,
and they forget
what we said, they
can go back and
look at it again,
which is not what happens
in person when they're
meeting with us in the lab.
So I have to admit that when
I got the email about winning
a Digital Technology
Teaching Award,
I thought it was
a joke or a scam
because I am famously
clueless with technology.
I have to get my
students to set it up
if I need a class e-list or a
Google Doc or what have you.
We also use technology
to travel virtually
when we couldn't
do it in real life,
for example, by walking city
streets in Google View mode,
visiting museum rooms,
browsing restaurant menus.
For some sections of the
course, I flipped the classroom.
What this means
is that I recorded
lectures, narrated some slides
and sent those out in advance.
And then during the synchronous
remote class time period
on Zoom, we use that time
to have more discussions,
mini cases, work out problems.
And we also discussed
the real-time changes
that were happening in the
US tax code in response
to the pandemic.
Virtual class
discussions just tend
to stall at unexpected moments.
And when that happened,
what helped for me
was to use breakout rooms.
Learning objectives
can be achieved
in many different ways.
We might be used to
achieving a learning
objective in a
particular way that's
been done for many years.
I think the transition
to online teaching
has made us take a step back and
acknowledge that perhaps there
are multiple ways to
get at that objective.
I designed a variety of
games anywhere from bingo
to Battleship.
Some ideas worked
better than others,
but students embraced
these experiments
with incredible
flexibility and good humor.
I've been asked what
did we do to create
appealing and
thought-provoking lectures?
Here are some tips.
1, lectures are stories.
2, design for the media.
We're used to seeing videos
with cuts every 2.5 seconds.
Keep it moving.
And 3, it's OK to have fun.
Lots of the activities
in my classes
are role-play
simulations or scenarios
that put students
in specific contexts
that mimic real-world or
professional practice contexts.
Ask them to use what they've
been reading and talking about,
and then give each
other feedback.
And then we often
video what they're
doing so they can see how
they're presenting themselves
to other people in
other people's eyes.
I really appreciated and enjoyed
the discussions via Zoom.
The students were really willing
to engage and ask questions.
And I felt we could create not
quite, but almost a classroom
atmosphere.
We've learned in this
digital teaching environment
to bring Socratic
dialogue, which
allows students to be the agents
who educate each other and us,
the instructors.
It's been a very powerful
way of teaching students
how to discover for themselves.
I can't thank you
enough for this.
I'll never forget our class.
I'll never forget
the spring of 2020.
And I look forward to see
you all on campus again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]